no story is complete without a good kiss
and a kiss done right at the perfect
moment
can mark the definitive moment in a
movie that goes doubly for last kisses
too
whether they're long or short
bittersweet or devastating
these are the best last kisses in movie
history
inevitably many last kisses in the
movies tend to be tinned with a touch of
tragedy
and ridley scott's gladiator takes her
role to its heart-wrenching extreme
in gladiator hispano-roman soldier
maximus faithfully serves the roman
emperor marcus aurelius
who selects him to be his heir over his
own cern commodus
romans being romans a commodus decides
to kill his father
before the decision becomes official
when maximus refuses to serve the new
emperor
commodus has him arrested maximus soon
escapes however
and rides home to his wife and son only
to find that they and everyone else on
their farm have been killed by
communists as men
it's here that maximus tearfully kisses
his wife scorched feet
before collapsing in despair he's then
kidnapped by a slave trader
and well the whole gladiator part of the
movie happens compounded by han zimmer
and lisa gerrard's powerful score
this scene provides a rare glimpse of
emotion in a movie better known for his
epic fight sequences
it reminds the audience that behind
maximus's soldierly exterior he's just a
man who loves his wife and son
it's also the moment that sets up
gladiator's iconic ending
in which a victorious maximus finally
reunites with his family in the
afterlife
everybody knew going in that titanic was
never going to end well
nonetheless you still can't help but get
emotionally invested in the romance
between society girl rose
and broke artist jack jack and rose's
most famous kiss of course
is that full-blown make-out session on
the ship's bow long before things go
wrong
but it's not their last now figuring out
which of their kisses is technically
their last is actually a little tricky
obviously jack and rose don't have a lot
of time for pdas
as they're trying to escape a sinking
ship later however after jack perishes
in the icy waters of the atlantic
rose kisses his frozen hands in a final
goodbye
and promises to never let go i'll never
let go
[Applause]
rose then immediately lets go she does
hold on to his memory though which in
hindsight
is probably what she meant during the
movie's final scene
jack and rhodes reunite at last on the
titanic's first class staircase
they're surrounded by other passengers
who cheer when the couple kisses one
last time
is this a dream it's rose in the
afterlife the meaning of the scene is
deliberately vague
but watching these two characters
reunite after 83 years with a kiss for
the ages
or thor even the iciest of hearts not
all last kisses happen between lovers
take thelma and louise for example in
this movie best friends thelma and
louise leave the former's controlling
husbands behind
for a fun weekend on the road instead
they end up killing a man who attacks
thelma
going on the run picking up a drifter
robbing a convenience store
and blowing up a truck but the best
final kiss in this movie isn't between
thelma and her new drifter lover jd
or between louise and her on off
boyfriend parked by the grand canyon
with a motorcade of cops behind them
the two friends on the run decide to go
out with the bank and they mark their
final moments with a kiss
unlike many movie kisses between women
this kiss is neither salacious nor
played to titillate straight male
audience members
it's just a moment of true love between
two friends in the 20th anniversary
edition blu-ray commentary
susan sarandon took credit for this
moment saying i had mentioned to gina
that i was going to kiss her but i don't
think ridley scott the director knew
fortunately sarandon pulled it off and
the moment of movie history was born
in moulin rouge the tragedy of the last
kiss between tragically impoverished
writer christian
and aspiring actress sateen is that it
comes in the wake of a major victory for
the couple
the pair have finally oust sateen's
controlling patron
the duke and delivered their vibrant
wild bohemian musical to la
bella park but thanks to an opening
scene featuring a devastated christian
the audience has known all along that
something is going to go wrong
and by the time the movie's grand
musical finale comes to a close
sateen is also well aware that she is
suffering from a fatal bout of
consumption
as christian slowly realizes what's
happening he holds her kissing her
softly
as she begs him to tell their story
their final scene brings together the
fantastical moulin rouge stylization
with a sense of heartbreakingly
authentic human drama
as writer and director baslerman told
the guardian it's about the transition
of youthful idealism to when you realize
that there are things bigger than you
people die some relationships cannot be
and you are destroyed by that
theater fans will tell you that william
shakespeare wrote the ultimate final
kiss
back in the late 16th century but some
400 years later
master of stylistic drama baslerman
decided to put a new spin on
shakespeare's version with his film
version of romeo and juliet
the shakespearean dialogue remained but
the swords became guns
the costumes were updated and a fish
tank of all things
played a prominent part in the iconic
couple's meet cute shakespeare suddenly
became 90s cool
thanks in large part to leonardo
dicaprio and claire danes
who breathed life into the iconic star
crossed lovers and then of course
killed them both off in the most brutal
way possible the cliff knows version of
the ending is that romeo believing that
juliet is dead
breaks into her tomb intending to kill
himself juliet who is only sedated
wakes up just as he downs a deadly
poison
[Music]
juliet then turns romeo's gun on herself
this morbid moment turns the hallmark of
young love into a deadly weapon
just as a couple's forbidden love
ultimately led to their doom
shakespearean love takes more than a few
liberties with history and doesn't shy
away from playing with some
tongue-in-cheek humor
still the love story at the heart of it
all feels absolutely authentic
the wealthy viola is prevented from
acting on the london stage by both her
social status and gender
so she dresses up as a man and lands the
starring role in a new play called ethel
the pirate's daughter
by some mediocre playwright named will
shakespeare shakespeare soon falls in
love with viola and the two begin an
affair after shakespeare figures out how
his leading actor and his crush are the
same person
he even starts writing the play that
becomes romeo and juliet
based on their relationship but these
star-crossed lovers are doomed
from the start viola is engaged to evil
lord wessex
and they're planning on moving to
virginia even though they marry on the
morning of the play
viola rushes back to the theatre through
various circumstances
shakespeare and viola end up playing
romeo and juliet respectively
but when the play ends to thunderous
applause they have to say goodbye
viola kisses will one more time then
leaves without looking back
it's a devastating unavoidable goodbye
in which the two lovers leading the
story don't get what they want
which seems apt considering the context
for such an epic love story cold
mountain doesn't have many kissing
scenes but it does make the few that
happen really count
ada is a fancy charleston lady who falls
for silent and sturdy country boy inman
when she and her father moved to cold
mountain north carolina
in 1861 inman goes to fight for the
confederacy in the civil war the two
kiss passionately before he leaves
then spend the next three years apart
only able to communicate with each other
through the letters they
write after a ferocious battle enman
abandons the army and sets out on a long
journey home
the two are eventually reacquainted but
the next day
inman gets into a shootout with a home
guardsman who's been pursuing
aida he kills the man but is fatally
wounded himself
ada holds him as he dies kissing his
forehead and comforting him
by the time you get it in man and ada's
last kiss you've seen that both of them
go through so much to reunite that it
feels blisteringly unfair that they
don't get a happy ending
sadly though their ill-fated romance
tells the same story of countless lovers
who have been doomed by wartime and
human cruelty
not many teens have a ghost as a best
friend but in 1995's casper
cat is used to the supernatural thanks
to her dad's paranormal investigations
as a result she meets the ghost casper
when they're moving to his ancestral
home
whipstaff manor although their initial
meeting is a little awkward
casper wins over kat and her dad james
but there's more to it than that
casper has had a crush on cat since even
before they met having seen a news
report about james's work
sadly the whole being dead thing throws
a significant wrench in there would-be
romance
however in the basement casting casper
conveniently discovered the lazarus
machine
which casper's father build to bring his
son back to life but there's only enough
formula for one ghost to human
transformation
and when james dies in an accident
casper sacrifices his shots at
resurrection
so that cat doesn't have to lose her dad
as thanks cat's mom returns from the
afterlife and makes casper human
but only for the night of cat's
halloween party casper dances with cats
and they kiss
right as he turns back into his ghost
form it's sweet it's sad and it's also a
little funny
what more could you ask of a final kiss
the sexiest kiss in 1990's ghost
obviously happens during the famous
pottery scene but the last kiss between
demi moore's molly and patrick swayze
sam
is by far the most emotionally resonant
of the movie and maybe one of the
all-time greats to boot
after being killed by a mugger sam
becomes a ghost you know hence the name
of the movie
while he can see his girlfriend molly
she doesn't know he's there
sam then stumbles across a supposedly
fake psychic odometer who can actually
hear and see him
oda may tries to convince molly that
she's communicating with sam but a grief
stricken molly is skeptical
meanwhile some learns to move physical
objects with his ghostly energy
and eventually he rescues oda may and
molly from the man who had him killed
suddenly molly can see and hear some too
he realizes that now that he's saved her
and avenged his own death he has to move
to the afterlife
so sam and molly say goodbye with a kiss
it's amazing molly
[Music]
love inside take it with you
swayze and moore nailed the
bittersweetness of this final kiss
in fact it was swayze's audition for
this scene that convinced the previously
skeptical filmmakers to cast him
and more perfectly balances her
character's frankly understandable sense
of confusion
joy and sadness altogether it just works
there's a reason this was the biggest
movie of the year in 1990 you know
if there was a movie kisses hall of fame
and there should be the notebook
definitely has a place in it
thanks entirely to one particular scene
lumber mill worker noah and aerys alley
defy her family's attempts to tear them
apart
and triumphantly reunite with a
passionate kiss in the middle of a
summer rainstorm
that moment when ryan gosling and rachel
mcadams are coveted mtv movie award
for best kiss in 2005 and immediately
went down in cinema history
but it's noah and ali's final kiss
that's the most powerful having grown
all together
they both come down with various
illnesses and are taken to the same
hospital
ali who can barely remember noah is in
the dementia ward
or noah is in for a heart attack but
noah sneaks into ali's room and she
briefly recognizes him
after the two decide that they want to
pass away together they kiss one last
time
a kiss in the rain has all the passion
of a long-delayed young romance but the
final kiss contains a true love and
understanding of a couple
who really lived up to their promise to
love each other until the end no matter
what
james bond is lucky and lust but never
in love in 2006's casino royale however
it looks like the playboy spy had
finally met as much both romantically
and professionally in west berlin
so as charming as you are mr bond i will
be keeping my eye on our government's
money
and offer you perfectly formed house you
noticed
the two make it through a dangerous plot
involving shady organizations creepy
villains
and an eye-watering torture scene and
are rewarded for it with a romantic
vacation in venice
bond even plans to resign from mi6 until
he learns that vesper has betrayed him
having stolen the money bond won in a
high stakes poker game on behalf of the
people holding her former leather
hostage when the deal goes bad
vesper is taken captive by bad guys and
bond manages to take them out one by one
but as the building they're in starts to
sink
vesper locks herself in an elevator and
refuses to let bond save her
he's eventually able to get her out and
back to the surface but his kiss of life
quickly turns into a kiss goodbye
now bond movies have had their fair
share of last kisses over the years but
this one is particularly
special bonds farewell to the one woman
he truly loved
resonates well beyond the end of the
movie and sets up the character's arc
for the rest of daniel craig's time in
the role
otherwise known as wonder woman diana
prince has had no experience kissing
human men
when she and u.s pilot steve trevor
first meet but the unlikely pair still
pull off a truly romantic final kiss
before hero duty calls of course
after wonder woman has marched through
the no man's land of 1917
and liberated the village of veld a
well-deserved celebration is in order
so steve offers to teach you how to
dance like humans do
you're awfully close
that's what it's all about but all those
sparks fly
neither steve nor diana can imagine
living an ordinary life together
they go to a hotel room in the village
and nervously kiss
and that's all the audience gets to see
sadly for diana the war gets between
them
and steve ends up leaving her in the
middle of a battle with a declaration of
love but no goodbye kiss
if you're the kind of person who gets a
kick out of watching the slow painful
disintegration of a once hopeful romance
that has long become tortured and
twisted
then boy is blue valentine the movie for
you cindy and dean fall in love at
second sight when she's a pre-med
student
and he's delivering furniture when cindy
finds out she's pregnant with her
ex-boyfriend's child
she and dean get married five years
later their relationship is cracking
under his drinking their money worries
and her despondency despite their best
attempts at salvaging the relationship
things only get worse from there
eventually cindy tells dean they have to
break up
but he tries to convince her that they
should stay together he walks over to
her and hugs her
even as cindy tenses up in his arms and
kisses her on the forehead the physical
contradiction of his hug and her
stiffness
reflects the simple and tragic fact that
they don't fit together emotionally
anymore
what was once a gesture of love becomes
a difficult goodbye
and the scene's closing moments intercut
with footage from their wedding day
shows just how far they've come from
their hopeful younger selves
the lovers in 1945's brief encounter
mostly convey their electric chemistry
through
well basically anything other than
kissing so when they do finally smooch
sparks really sizzle laura is a bored
housewife with a kind but dull husband
in 1940s england
her weekly highlight is taking the train
to the nearby town of milford
waiting at the milford station one day
she meets a charming doctor alec
who's also married with kids after
accidentally meeting again
they begin a covert relationship
eventually after a few near misses
the couple decide they can't continue
their affair and spend one final day
together
the heart-wrenching twist is that they
don't even get a private goodbye
at their last meeting they're
interrupted by one of laura's friends
alec has to leave to catch his train and
all he can do is squeeze laura on the
shoulder
the final kiss of the movie takes place
earlier when the author interrupted by
the arrival of a friend
and even this was a brave move in the
filmmaker's part brief encounter was
considered so scandalous because of its
adultery that it was initially banned in
ireland
while movies today are freer to show
kisses even adulterous kisses this one
is
all more powerful for being a daring
expression of rule-breaking passion
if there's one movie that best sums up
the burden of impossible love
it's casablanca grouchy american rick
blaine is keeping a low profile in
casablanca during world war
ii when his long-lost love esau lund
walks into his gin joint
accompanied by her husband jack
resistance leader victor lazlow
rick hasn't seen eosir since the
previous summer when they fell in love
in paris
only for her to abandon him suddenly now
she and laszlo are trying to reach
america to escape the nazis
and rick has the exit papers they need
in order to get out reunited and still
very much in love
he also and rick plan to use the papers
to leave together
but rick has a change of heart and puts
laszlo and eosir on the plane
knowing that laszlo needs ill sir to
continue his important work
many people think that rick and elsa's
last kiss happens at the airport but
come on that would have been a giveaway
to her husband the kiss actually happens
at rick's apartment the night before
when eagle sir declares her love for
rick at long last he also and wreck them
release all that pen to belonging in a
perfectly shot dramatically soundtracked
kiss
which inevitably proves to be their last
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]